fue uno de los primeros ídolos del
fútbol francés
se le recuerda por haber hecho soñar a
Francia cuando por primera vez en la
historia la Selección del país galo
llegó a semifinales en el mundial de
Suecia de 1958 perdieron contra el
Brasil de Pelé en esa Copa del Mundo
fonta anotó 13 goles en Solo siete
partidos un récord dentro de una sola
edición de la copa y que sigue vigente
así se consagró como referencia de Esta
generación acompañado por gemuncopa y
sus aliados de La delantera del
embledore punta era el único que
permanecía con vida con copa escribieron
la primera epopeya del fútbol francés
Just frontal será para siempre nuestro
mito fundacional a su familia sus seres
queridos
envía sus más sinceras condolencias
en 1933 de Padre francés y madre
española
comenzó a jugar al fútbol en lo que en
Entonces era el protectorado francés de
Marruecos desarrollo gran parte de su
carrera en el stat de arrans con estos
colores ganó tres títulos de liga en
Francia la copa de Francia en el 58 y
disputó la final de la entonces copa de
Europa en 1959 a lo largo de su carrera
se estima que anotó 256 goles
no tenía la mejor técnica pero sí tenía
buena técnica no tenía un disparo muy
fuerte pero le podía pegar bien con las
dos piernas no era el mejor con la
cabeza pero saltaba bien era bastante
completo sin embargo su carrera como
jugador tuvo punto final en 1962 cuando
con solo 28 años Tuvo una doble fractura
en una de sus piernas
en su época como director técnico llevó
a esta primera división al París
saint-germain hace más de 50 años
también fue pionero en derechos para los
futbolistas franceses al crear el primer
sindicato de jugadores profesionales de
fútbol en el país galo